la región de américa latina y el caribe
paso el sombrío umbral del millón de
muertos por coronavirus la mayoría de
los decesos más de 446.000 se concentran
en brasil que tiene el segundo brote más
mortal del mundo si nos salimos de la
casa no hacemos nada fuera de la casa
porque tenemos miedo incluso aunque
estemos trayendo la vacuna tenemos muy
rica pero para donar el número de
muertes a brasil les sigue en méxico y
colombia según reuters
los tres países combinados suman el 74
por ciento de las muertes producidas en
américa latina' por el virus tuvimos la
oportunidad de prepararnos para de
alguna manera estar mejor cuando la
enfermedad llegara dijo que al contrario
de prepararnos lo que hicimos fue
minimizar la enfermedad
argentina vive actualmente su peor etapa
de la pandemia desde el inicio del brote
desde este sábado entran en vigor las
medidas anunciadas por el presidente
alberto fernández con un confinamiento
en gran parte del país por nueve días lo
hacen a pesar de ya haber vivido una de
las cuarentenas más larga
del mundo si la situación es muy difícil
porque el colapso y la saturación en
cada hospital que no está pertenezco a
la interhospitalaria que es una red de
enfermería dentro de los hospitales
naturales y la situación se repite en
cada uno de estos los contagios siguen
en aumento en la región pero a pesar de
ello
américa latina y el caribe es una de las
regiones más rezagadas en vacunación en
suramérica sólo el 15 por ciento de la
población ha recibido al menos una dosis
de un fármaco contra el virus en
comparación al 34 por ciento en américa
del norte y el 28% en europa además de
un avance lento en la inoculación la
región se enfrenta a la muy desigual
distribución de los fármacos para
prevenir la enfermedad